the media wants you to believe that joe
biden is the candidate of
empathy and compassion joe cares but my
next guest
is living proof that that is false
former
boxer professional boxer charles duke
tanner
was sentenced to 30 years in prison on
federal drug charges
but upon entering prison tanner says he
immediately began working to improve
himself
and atone of course for his crimes and
president trump
took notice granting mr tanner clemency
just last week
something president obama had declined
to do
president trump i just want to thank you
for giving me a second chance first i
didn't know it was real
until i was able to bring touch this
little guy right here
i left him when he was two years old
president trump you reunited me back
to my family i lost my mother and my
father but i got him
and this is what i live for thank you
president trump
most of us who watch that for the first
time were in tears uh
second chances duke tanner joins me now
duke
how did you find out it was great to see
you tonight and how did you find out the
president was
the impetus behind your release
um i really didn't didn't know what was
going on because
my unit team came and got me after four
o'clock p.m count and was like they
needed to talk to me
and you know he said um i got to get you
out of here
i said where i'm going he said well the
president granted you clemency
i just started sweating and praying and
praising god
next thing you know i was in a hotel
waiting to um go to philly to the
airport
and your your son just your moment with
your son in that video
uh it just hit hit me in the heart as a
mom
what was that like seeing him when you
could really spend time with him
without other people watching
you know that situation with my faith
and my belief in
my lord and savior jesus christ on how i
got my the free gift from him from what
he did on the cross
the second best gift in life was given
to me
by president donald president donald
trump
that day when i was able to be in my
cell in life
and reunited with him something that i
was given a life sentence a double life
sentence at first that was reduced to 30
years
so that day right there is the second
best thing besides getting my salvation
being free and being in my son's life
i want to play something for you um duke
that
joe biden said about president trump
during that last debate
watch abraham lincoln here is one of the
most racist presidents we've had in
modern history
he pours fuel on every single
racist fire every single one he has
moved
around and made everything worse across
the board
this guy is a dog whistle about as big
as a foghorn
duke uh it's not just biden claiming the
president's racist but athletes
celebrities
lobbed this charge routinely do you
think president trump
is a racist um for one
i never met president trump a day in my
life
but what i can say is i know miss alex
marie johnson
hershey walker was one of my favorite
football players
and i think they got too high of
integrity and dignity
to hang out with the races and what
president trump did for me
a black man i can't say that he's a
racist
on my belief now what other people say
this world they got their own opinion
but what he done for me like i said
the second best thing to get in your
salvation
by jesus christ and if you're a believer
in god
you'll understand what that means and
how important that means
that's the second best gift he gave me
so i can never
say that he's a racist and that's where
i stand in my humble opinion
duke i've got to say second chances and
who who among us
hasn't needed a second chance and i
think your witness
and just your personal story is really
moving
beyond politics and everything else and
uh we just really appreciate your coming
on and
we wish you the best of luck with your
family and thanks for joining us tonight
thank you so much and thank everybody in
the trump administration and
who have something to do with um my
freedom for sending me back to my boy
to show true redemption and that's what
i would do i'm gonna make you all proud
president trump i'm gonna make you proud
of me i promise thanks for reading my
petition
god bless you